[MUSIC PLAYING]
TIMOTHY JORDAN: Hello.
I'm Timothy Jordan for
The Developer Show.
This is your weekly update
on the coolest developer
news from Google.
ARCore and Sceneform give
you simple yet powerful tools
for creating augmented
reality experiences.
Version 1.7 of the
Google ARCore SDK
is now available and focuses
on creative elements,
like AR selfies and
animation, as well as
helping you improve the Core
user experience in your apps.
Details, screenshots, and
a link to the download
are on the post.
Model-based reinforcement
learning attempts
to have agents learn how the
world behaves in general.
Instead of directly mapping
observations to actions,
this allows an agent to
explicitly plan ahead
to more carefully select actions
by imagining their long term
outcomes.
To spur progress on
this research challenge
and in collaboration
with DeepMind,
we recently released the
Deep Planning Network Agent,
which learns a world
model from image inputs
only and successfully
leverages it for planning.
Take a look at the post
for a lot of detail
and a link to the source code.
We've recently made enhancements
to the audience builder
experience in Google
Analytics for Firebase,
with a few major updates to
help you identify relevant app
audiences more easily and
with greater precision.
Audiences are now
dynamic by default,
can be more precisely defined
by adding exclusion criteria,
and can now include a
membership time frame.
More details and a
screenshot are on the post.
Jib is an open source tool
that containerizes your Java
applications with
minimal effort.
Simply apply the
plugin to your Maven
or Gradle build
and run the build.
Jib 1.0.0 is now
generally available,
making it stable
for production use.
Take a look at the
post for some examples.
Are you going to the RSA
Conference in San Francisco
next month?
Well, so are members of
the Google Cloud team.
Check out this post for a link
to talks at the RSA Conference,
as well as a link to the
Google Cloud Security Talks,
a series of 20 talks over just
two days, five minutes away
from the Moscone Center.
Please remember to like,
subscribe, and share.
I'm Timothy Jordan for
The Developer Show.
Thanks for watching, and
we'll see you next week.
And we'll see you next week,
as well as in the next take.
Because I will have
been reading this text
at least two times by then.